The Walking Dead is back with the New
Aesthetic time setting and direction for
the show throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything you need to
know about Episode six who are you now
and where relieves our characters there
will of course be heavy spoilers so if
you haven't seen the episode yet then I
highly recommend that you come back to
this video after watching it with that
out the way I'm definition and I roon it
so you don't have to episode six
fittingly picks up six years after the
apparent death of main character Rick
Grimes in the previous episode we were
introduced to a new group of survivors
and in older Judith Grimes who had taken
the role of being the new sheriff in
town
in Episode six we learn the ins and outs
of the new characters as well as what
happened in the six years since we last
saw our heroes daryl is now a lone wolf
that stalks the landscape and he's
clearly accepted that zombies are part
of the ecosystem now and this is
confirmed when he lets one live because
he sees a bird using the worms on its
carcass to feed its young wings the
biggest shock to me came when I learned
that priest Gabriel was hooking up with
Rosita now and that Eugene had lost his
male I just guess there's no one handing
out trendy haircuts in the zombie
apocalypse at the kingdom and Carol is
walking around looking like Legolas now
but her and Zeke reside over there
Kingdom Carol is still a badass though
and she by far has the best moment in
the episode mirroring this female
superiority is Michonne who is now
security chief of Alexandria we learned
that wreck in fact did impregnate her
and that rick has another child running
around the apocalypse that I'm sure will
be picked up upon when the character
returns for his three original movies
Michonne isn't happy that the new group
are breaking their no new people rule
and seems to distrust them slightly at
the end she sets off for hilltop which
doesn't have Maggie but we don't find
out exactly why I can't imagine the new
people going over to smoothly there
especially when we learn about the
weapons they snuff past the group and
their lives before the
because Michelle and Judith seemed to
have inherited Rick's ability to
hallucinate the dead and it's nice that
Rick and call shadow still lingers over
the world in a positive way that guides
them through the tough landscape negan
now seems to be becoming a positive
influence and we see that he has become
Judith's math teacher negan actually
seems happy again after the emotional
wreck that he was last episode but that
doesn't mean he's changed completely and
Judith keeps a watchful eye over him we
also see Rosita and Eugene at the side
of the road hiding out like it's Lord of
the Rings and being stalked by the
whisperers the whisperers say you let
them let them go it I can't do otherwise
you let them get away but everyone that
doesn't know basically the whisperers
are the show's new central villain and
they are people that disguised
themselves as the undead and walk
amongst them their name comes from the
whispering that they're able to do which
doesn't away at the walkers and lets
them carry on under the camouflage so
what are your thoughts on the new
direction that the Walking Dead is
taking are you enjoying the new
characters and what would you like to
see before the season's end comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of
Magnus group which will be linked to at
the end of this one this is a channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like uni is subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]